if trump was president today
would putin have done this
i don't know
if trump was president today would the
taliban have taken over afghanistan many
will say no
and many on the left like matt zeller
who was a former cia who cannot stand
trump cannot stand tulsi gabbard he
called that tulsi gabbard did you see
what he said on the tweet he he sent me
the tweet this is what he called tulsa
yeah but tulsi gabbard tweeted out this
yesterday
17 hours ago she says this war and
suffering could have easily been avoided
if biden administration nato had simply
acknowledged russia's legitimate
security concerns regarding ukraine's
becoming a member of nato which would
mean u.s nato forces
right on russia's border and he responds
you're a traitor and a coward resign
your commission and go home to your
handlers in moscow right so zeller is
not a fan of tulsi ziller's not a fan of
trump but he's still not happy about the
way biden handled
the afghanistan issue with taliban so
would it have been different if trump
was here
is are they kind of looking at this
opportunity and saying hey you know
this is a good time for both of us to go
in let's capitalize i'll get taiwan you
get ukraine it's a perfect perfect time
to do it under
biden he won't do anything about it so
for those that said that
well
biden kind of put some strong sanctions
on putin and russia like it's not like
he didn't do anything about it he put
the sanctions now is that gonna be
enough i don't know
a lot of people were saying oh it's just
a bluff
putin's just a bluff he always says this
it's a bluff this wasn't a bluff folks
right this is real people died there's
videos of bombings all over the place
which many of us are probably saying at
this point if we play the clips it's
probably replaced of what you've already
seen yourself
tyler i don't know if you have access to
one of them if you can play one of them
when the jet drops those two bombs
and you see the kids screaming
and you see the woman with the blood on
her face i don't know if you have it
ready or not if you do play it if you
don't we can continue yeah so i think
this is it here i'm gonna share my
screen really quick and we'll get it
all right pbd we're going to play this
video now
press play and hit the audio because the
audio is down right now turn on the
audio first turn on okay there you go
[Music]
i didn't hear the audio i don't know if
you guys heard the audio or not because
okay good did you guys hear the audio
okay so if you want to pause that and
and i mean that kid's screaming my kids
screamed last night at 4 o'clock when
she woke me up because she wanted to
have their diapers changed and she
wanted to eat that's a different scream
than this scream that's painful as a
parent hearing what many of these
families are going through people are
blown away that this thing like
i don't mean it like they're they're
surprised on what's going on nobody
expected it to escalate to this point
right now
[Music]